i don't see amanda when i'm watching
this i see good ideas that's exactly
what i want to hear thank you that voice
the stature and can we please talk about
those dance moves
how did you get into character to
capture those moves i mean was it just
spontaneity was it choreographed it
wasn't choreographed that's for sure
i mean there was one dance that we had a
choreographer who was amazing we had so
much fun trying to find the right moves
for that the beginning of the first one
and the second episode but all this
other
spontaneous dancing that elizabeth
character does
and that sunny and naveen's character
does
it's just um old-fashioned dance skills
or like finding the wrong move or
finding that weird
awkward rhythm that you want to hide
yeah like really getting in touch with
the worst dancer
and that awkwardness is kind of what
brings us all together as as audience
members like we're all kind of we have
awkward
you know tendencies and moments
tendencies yeah and i'm just like bring
it out i want to see more of that i want
to see more of that and everything and
that's why liz merriweather is like the
perfect person to
dive into this the headspace of this
character especially cast is insanely
talented i mean across the board it was
a joy to work on and watching it back
there's no weak link i mean you you
don't look for weak links yeah but
i mean you couldn't find one if you
tried so it's everybody loves being in
it i think that's the number one thing
and you know they're so good there's so
many people that came to be involved in
this it was just like i was surrounded
by these
macy and sam waters i mean just the
yeah endless talent and honey you are
having a moment amanda you know i've
never had anything like this before you
just have this momentum of
seemingly roll after roll that you are
capturing and knocking out of the park
what are you making particularly of this
series the reaction that fans are giving
you right now we're about we still have
three episodes left so what do you make
of the buzz and the reaction um
i think i think
you know there's a
i think it's just we're making really
good television i also think that um
i was given the opportunity to play
somebody that i that i've
i've had a lot of fun with it was
thrilling to get a chance to have my own
interpretation of this this very
enigmatic person
and so i just you know having the
opportunity to do that and they get to
show people that it's just
and then hope and hopefully like i hope
part of the reason people are loving it
is that they're they don't see
an actor they're just
you know
being drawn in by the the characters
like this this feels like very much like
a character piece for every single actor
involved and i think that's
i think that's the difference between a
lot of stuff i've gotten to do
and i mean they're real people but
they're they're characters they are
characters indeed but if elizabeth tunes
in and watches the show what do you hope
she takes from it i hope she takes that
you know there's a group of people who
are um
trying to humanize her in a way that i
don't think anyone has tried to do
before i think she's um the story is
incredible
um a lot of things went wrong there are
a lot of bad choices made and she's a
human being at the center of it um we
can't forget that she's multifaceted
we all are we all are i mean for for
better for worse and i and i at least
hope she takes away that this might be
the most sympathetic
um
uh
perspective that that that exists in
terms of you know what we what we've
seen of her
[Music]